when it comes to marvel trailers every
moments are something important to say
and come to the promise of deeper
meanings hidden explanations and
misleading miss directions let's break
it down and take a look at more details
you may have missed in the newest
Avengers endgame trailer the new trailer
featured a group of heroes walking
through the Avengers hangar if the scene
from the trailer felt familiar that's a
good reason for that a Super Bowl spot
also ended on a quick T's of a string of
heroes walking through the same hangar
the thing is each trailer seems to be
showing distinctly different groups of
people at different times the big game
clips seem to depict cap Thor Black
Widow rocket ant-man war machine and
either Bruce Banner or Clint Barton they
also appear to be wearing their normal
super suits this time around the setting
remained but the shot showed cap ant-man
Hawkeye war machine Black Widow Iron Man
and nebula all sporting new suits that
look an awful lot like a variation on
Hank Pym quantum realm suits or even the
space armor that the hero's done than
the cartoons what's going on here why do
we have two nearly identical shots with
completely different groups and suits is
happening right now it doesn't matter
good
whenever ends game takes place
speculation is running high that it will
showcase a sizable jump forward in time
in the newest trailer we get a clip of
clint barton with what appears to be his
family the next shot is a repeat from
the last trailer showing the distress
button with a completely different
haircuts then there's black widow she
ended infinity war was short blonde hair
but in the trailer she's shown with long
hair that drapes past her shoulders her
hair also goes from blonde to her
natural red and that takes time to grow
out Black Widow seems to be the big clue
that we are dealing with some sort of
time jump between movies the first
trailer had a moment showing Steve
Rogers looking at a compass with agent
Peggy Carter spitzer in it's a touching
reminder of how far the man has come
since he was a scrawny kid desperately
trying to fight for his country although
apparently it wasn't just a callback to
an emotional past because caps old flame
can be heard in a voiceover drawing the
new trailer to
changed
sound familiar is the same line she said
as caps up by her deathbed in Winter
Soldier the world has changed
none of us all we can do is our best
and sometimes the best we can do is to
start over
whatever the implications might be the
appearance of Peggy and the new trailer
is starting to make us wonder how she
might fit into the bigger picture the
slow-mo walk through the HQ hangar was
dripping with teasers but the new suits
and appearance of Tony Stark and nebula
made it easy to miss one of the biggest
questions at the scene posed where were
Bruce Banner Thor and Carol Danvers we
now know thanks to that last tag at the
end of the new trailer along with the
mid-credits scene from our own movie
that Danvers will be joining up with the
team which makes her absence from the
hangar scene at that much more
conspicuous does the scene take place
before she arrives the absence of both
banner and Thor is even more puzzling
both to be around from the beginning of
the film as they were among the
survivors of the snap we're still
waiting for the three movie yard for
hope that Mark Ruffalo spoken about so
Hulk's almost guaranteed to be in the
movie somewhere what about Thor Asgard
is destroyed and he has Stormbreaker so
there's little need to be off elsewhere
on his own personal errands at this
point why are the three most powerful
members of the team not present it seems
like a bit of a handicap if the group is
going up against Thanos another
intriguing detail is easy to miss during
that Hangul walk and it has to do with
an Avenger that typically doesn't get
much screen time Rhodey always playing
the number two - Tony Rhodey was
nevertheless a solid presence throughout
infinity war doing everything he could
to help keep the enemy contained on the
battlefield of Wakanda in fact it seemed
a shame that it was a sheepish banner
that ended up donning the Hulkbuster
armor when the much more experienced
Iron patriot was standing by fans have
been looking for a war machine decked
out in Hulkbuster armor ever since
spotting a Hulkbuster war machine Lego
set planned for endgame while it doesn't
come across as quite Hulkbuster size the
armor Rhodey is wearing in the clip is
undeniably a bit beefier than normal
whether the team is heading into the
quantum realm or space it makes sense
that Rhodey would want a little bit more
protection or maybe he just wanted more
room to pack weapons then I figure I'll
take it which one all of it
the theme of the first trailer tended to
revolve around loss not so with a second
this time the whole message can be
boiled down to three words whatever it
takes whatever it takes
[Music]
whatever it takes
it takes as the group is shown in
various capacities preparing to do
whatever it takes though there are four
people that stand out from the crowd
first to say the line escapa followed by
cleanse that than the tush er then
finally Tony Stark
whatever it takes while the mantra seems
like a good one for the film a question
is why do these four say it's both Chris
Evans and Robert Downey jr. have been
rumoured to be approaching the end of
their time in the MCU
but the thought that four of the
original six Avengers are ready to do
whatever it takes could imply a larger
culling than anyone was expecting check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite Marvel movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]